productname mango creamy soda
parentheses carbonated drink peering
down the bottle at what color this is
I'm like a little suspect of it oh look
at the milky white a little cloudy can
we say the thing we think it looks like
it looks like good luck yeah it tastes
like mango juice it tastes just like a
bunch of melted Haribo gummies yeah in
dirty water I would 100% drink this soda
I would definitely buy this at the store
because it's so tiny and I would love to
just carry it around and have people
comment pic oh cool oh what a surprise
oh it packs a punch it's like liquid
Smarties it's a cycle a little bit of a
Red Bull it's an entirely new taste to
me I like it it's okay cool
I see Hello Kitty and I know Hello Kitty
there's a paragraph of instructions on
how to sew down how this punch is place
the opener on top of the RAM UHN bottle
and press down firmly with your palm oh
my god am i doing it right as this point
lunch is over my lunch break is over
alright that's not bad
it's it's super sugary ah yeah that's
the worst one yet really I really like
it actually it reminds me of the the
frozen ice pops it seems like Jones soda
to me I would agree with that I think
like mixing this with alcohol at a party
would be fun
I noticed you just poured more of this I
went back for seconds there's I think
there's a chemical in this that's
controlling my brain more than my knee
what is that it kind of smells like
rotting fruit what does that smell like
hip what is that smell this sort of
angry at me no no the cancer tastes oh
god damn it
ah that's very unpleasant that's our um
sparkling cider yeah this makes my
tongue wanna leave my mouth
yeah like apple puree for babies yes
that's exactly baby in baby food soda oh
I have arrived
I shall take one tiny beer are you
enjoying the giant football game throw
me one of that tiny six-pack you got one
tiny beer for you one tiny beer